[Música]
no les pasó en alguna materia la
facultad que les pidieron un proyecto
ustedes se invierten un montón de tiempo
invierte un montón de recursos lo
entregan lo presentan los prueban y
viene la pregunta y ahora qué hago con
esto
con un compañero en el 2016 empezamos a
curso a proyecto final
nosotros no queríamos que nos vuelva a
pasar eso nosotros queríamos hacer algo
que haya más allá de lo académico algo
que realmente les pueda servir a alguien
no teníamos ni idea de qué hacer
empezamos a hablar con compañeros con
amigos con docentes papeles sugerencias
nos dan ideas increíbles un compañero en
un asado mi hijo porque no hace es un
drone tabar para la idea
pero le voy a probar iba a volar 23 días
que iba a terminar guardando una caja me
iba a quedar en la nada
en ese momento tuvimos la posibilidad
con mi compañero de hablar con un
docente que estaba empezando un grupo de
investigación él tenía un objetivo y una
idea muy clara él quería hacer una
herramienta para ayudar a personas una
herramienta para ayudar a personas que
no se podían comunicar de forma natural
yo lo que le dije a mi hijo mira es
bueno si nosotros trabajamos con ellos
posiblemente nuestro proyecto una vez
terminado no termina en la nada sino que
puede hacer un aporte a esta herramienta
con la cual la cual estaba pensando
nuestro lo que iba a hacer nuestro
director
y posiblemente pudiera ser ayudar a
alguien ese es el lugar donde nosotros
tenemos que trabajar
en ese momento nuestro director lo que
nos decía es bueno ustedes lo que tienen
que hacer es un programa que le muestre
dos palabras a una persona la persona se
tiene que concentrar en una de estas dos
palabras y el programa tiene que
informar en cuál de las dos palabras se
están concentrando la persona
agarren fia google empezó a buscar lo
que me estaban viendo encontré vídeos de
japón eeuu cosas de facebook contra todo
menos lo que yo necesitaba saber cómo
iba a hacer es lo único que sabemos con
mi compañero era que si necesitábamos de
alguna forma saber en qué se estaba
concentrando la persona necesitábamos
saber cómo era que estaba trabajando el
cerebro que estaba pasando cómo era la
señal era algo así como cuando el médico
hace un electroencefalograma y se pone a
ver la señal buscando algo nosotros
teníamos que hacer algo parecido
tener un casco que nos permita obtener
estas señales costaba 650 dólares
además que no teníamos esa plata si la
hubiéramos tenido teníamos que traer es
el casco del exterior en el 2016 había
problemas con importaciones no entraba
ese casco
si hubiera tenido la plata y lo hubiera
podido traer encima y vamos a tener que
pagar 50 dólares más por mes para poder
usarlo y poder obtener la señal que
nosotros necesitábamos imagina que si yo
les dieran una herramienta una persona y
tenés que pagar 650 dólares para
comprarlo lo tienes que traer de afuera
y encima pagar 50 dólares más
mensualmente y lo vas a poder usar
no los haría nadie que haría una caja
nosotros tuvimos la suerte en ese año de
que nos prestan ese casco podemos
terminar nuestro proyecto en diciembre
mi compañero se recibió de ingeniero yo
me iba a recibir al tiempo después pero
lo más importante era que habíamos
podido cumplir con nuestro objetivo y
que ese proyecto luego usar el grupo
para poder continuar en busca de su
herramienta y su objetivo final
nosotros nos habíamos comprometido tanto
en este trabajo que decimos seguir
participando en el 2017 ya no queríamos
mostrarle dos palabras a la persona
porque si nosotros queríamos hacer que
esa persona se pueda comunicar de forma
completa con 22 figuras dos palabras no
nos alcanzaba necesitaban buscar un
objetivo entonces lo que nos propuso el
profesor es agarrar nuestro programa y
ahora no mostrarle dos mostrarles seis
figuras
entonces funciona igual el programa la
persona se concentraba en una de estas
seis figuras que estaban destellando de
forma secuencial el programa decía te
estás concentrando en la que están
concentrando en la b enlace en la d en
la f
que este programa funcionará nos llevó
un poco menos de un año pero teníamos un
problema seguíamos usando un casco
comercial
de alguna forma había que empezar a ver
cómo hacer para reemplazar esa parte del
grupo de investigación empezó a buscar
alternativas en internet se cruzó con un
proyecto que se llamaba open vez 6
bbc y los cuentos una plaqueta que tiene
cables nos pone sensores esos sensores
se ponen en las lunas partes de la
cabeza y se obtienen las distintas
señales que es con lo cual el cerebro va
trabajando
el tema era bueno tenemos la plaqueta
perdón de la ponemos vamos en la mano en
el bolsillo arriba de los piernas y si
podríamos solucionar este problema donde
ponemos los sensores una persona no
estaba experimentado con esto es
imposible que se ponga bien los sensores
si las personas no se ponen bien los
sensores nuestro programa no funciona
entonces lo que hicimos fue imprimir un
casco con impresora 3d montamos nuestra
plaqueta en ese casco y quedaron
marcadas donde iba a cada uno de los
sensores entonces lo único que tenían
que hacer la persona era abrir el
programa y ponerse el casco
lo que vemos lograr un casco que era muy
equivalente al casco comercial con la
diferencia que éste solamente costaba lo
que era el armado no haya que pagar
ninguna licencia no hay que traerlo de
afuera uno lo armaba acá imprimía el
casco nosotros teníamos el programa y se
podía usar
estamos en lo que es la tercera etapa
del proyecto ya no le queremos mostrar
dos palabras o seis figuras a una
persona l queremos otras 36 figuras
entonces uno dice y por qué 36 siempre
menos es más fácil porque no vende
porque no 18 24 pero 36 es un número que
me permite poner todas las letras del
abecedario y todos los números del 0 al
9 entonces una persona se puede empezar
a concentrar en esta pantalla y puede
empezar a escribir oraciones y números
de teléfono
ahora pero para qué sirve todo esto
alguien conoce el helado la exploración
de tener amiotrófica
hay todos tímidos bueno es una pregunta
que tuve la posibilidad de dar preguntar
en varias ocasiones cuando se fue dando
esta charla y como que nosotros
encontramos tres grupos de personas a
los tímidos lo que no respondían después
estaban los que sabían con lujo de
detalles que era los que además
respondían con terminología médica que
había terminología que yo no sabía que
tenía que preguntar qué era lo que
estaban diciendo y después había un
tercer grupo que me decía ser yo la
verdad no tengo ni idea que es pero yo
vi una película de stephen hawking que
había quedado paralizado y que esa
enfermedad no le dejaba hablar
yo le digo que sí que es verdad
que eso es pero que no solamente él
tiene esta enfermedad solamente en
argentina hay 3000 casos con esta
enfermedad en el mundo se reportan 17
nuevos casos cada hora esta es una
enfermedad rara
y no tiene cura entonces es ahí donde
nuestro proyecto empieza ahora sentí
donde se puede ver el potencial de
nuestro proyecto laboral en nuestro
primer programa le mostramos a la
persona un signo cuántas preguntas uno
puede hacer por día que se responden con
un si uno cree salir que es comer
cualquier pregunta bien formulada se
puede responder con un signo
e incluso algo tan fácil como ofrecer a
un chico un chocolate y que lo pueda
aceptar o no
nuestro segundo programa le mostraba
seis figuras a la persona ya estábamos
aumentando la comunicación ya no había
que hacerle una pregunta por sí o por no
la persona podría tener distintas
acciones en esa figura solamente hacía
falta un poco de creatividad armar estas
tarjetas y las podíamos adaptar al
momento del día ya las necesidades de la
persona
hoy
y 9 de junio estoy acá en este evento
parado en esta alfombra tratando de no
irme acá
para contarles dos cosas la primera es
que yo cumplí con mi objetivo
yo me recibí ingeniero con este proyecto
la segunda
es que hoy este proyecto con la plata o
pvc y con el casco todo se puede
descargar y cualquiera lo púlsar
nosotros sabemos que esta herramienta no
es la cura de la enfermedad pero
seguramente si le llega a alguien y lo
usa puede mejorar la calidad de vida
yo les puedo asegurar que la
satisfacción que se siente el haber
desarrollado y el haber participado en
el armado de esta herramienta es uno de
los mejores regalos que me quedan de mi
paso por la facultad por eso yo quiero
que ustedes sientan la misma
satisfacción que yo siento y que cuando
salgan por la puerta y tengan que
encarar un nuevo proyecto ahora en todas
esas capacidades que nunca son pocas
todas las herramientas todos los
recursos que tienen disponible y busquen
cómo que cómo o qué proyecto hacer para
que una vez finalizado pueda impactar
socialmente muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]